Over the past 15 years, reality television
has transformed from a relatively non-existent
category into a well-oiled machine.
Tons of networks were quick to capitalize
on the trend and quickly reality TV shows
became high-rated primetime juggernauts.
Audiences love to tune in and watch everyday
people put in extraordinary situations.
But while these programs may be marketed as
reality, there are often people behind the
scenes who are pulling strings in ways you
might not realize.
Here are Screen Rant’s 10 Biggest Lies You
Believe About Reality TV Shows.
Keeping Up With The Kardashians
The Kardashians aren’t known for being authentic,
so it should come as no surprise that their
show isn’t either.
Camera crews follow the family as they spend
their days being famous on E! network’s
Keeping Up With The Kardashians.
And if that sounds boring to you, you’re
not alone.
The producers tend to agree, and will occasionally
mess with the show’s timeline to create
drama.
They’ve also been accused of using their
powers for other evils; to make some characters
more sympathetic than others.
Apparently Kim choreographed her entire engagement
to Kris Humphries, even demanding that it
be filmed over again.
Why?
She “didn’t like” the face she was making
in the original.
It seems that the real stars of this show
are editing, and reshoots.
Judge Judy
There’s a common saying amongst lawyers:
“always read the fine print.”
And if you can catch the fine print at the
end of an episode of Judge Judy, here’s
what you’ll learn.
The complainants in each case found their
way to Judge Judith Sheindlin’s courtroom
by way of a producer.
And that producer found them by lurking around
small-claims courts, listening for wacky cases.
At no cost to them, the participants are flown
to Los Angeles where they’re paid an appearance
fee.
Even the losers are winners.
The production company pays whatever fine
the Judge assigns at the end of each trial.
So if you’ve ever wondered what would possess
someone to appear on a show like this one,
now you know.
Cash Cab
How many times have you found yourself in
the back of a taxi, wishing for something
to make the time pass faster?
If only the driver would quiz you on your
general knowledge!
Then you’d BOTH be having fun!
Well, thanks to Cash Cab, there are a handful
of lucky commuters who made it to their destination
with fully stimulated brains, and a pocket
full of cash.
Except that they don’t actually keep the
cash.
They give it back and wait for their winnings
in the mail.
Oh, and the contestants?
Most of them are not random citizens on their
way to drinks with friends, or a night on
the down.
Nope.
They’re people who have been pre-screened
by producers.
And it’s disappointing when you realize
that not everyone has an equal shot at being
picked up by the Cash Cab.
COPS
Emerging during the middle of a writers strike
in 1988, the show COPS was born of necessity.
People were hungry for entertainment, and
in 1989, executives figured that nothing was
better than a story that told itself.
As if being arrested wasn’t bad enough,
suddenly there was the possibility that it
could happen in front of millions of people.
Plus, just because the crew was often in the
presence of law enforcement, it doesn’t
men they were safe.
And one staffer was accidentally killed during
filming.
Crews need special permission in order to
film with the police, and almost nobody says
yes.
They argue that their work isn’t for the
amusement of others.
If the cops don’t even want to be on COPS,
maybe it’s time shut it down.
Storage Wars
Look twice before you throw out that pile
of junk in the garage, because it might be
full of rare antique collectibles worth a
million dollars.
If tenants skip payments long enough, eventually
the contents of their locker are auctioned
off, which is the entire premise of Storage
Wars.
The catch is that the people bidding don’t
know what treasures lie within each unit.
They’re not allowed to touch anything until
the buyer is confirmed, and there’s something
crazy in every locker.
So after finding his share of outlandish stuff
in the abandoned lockers of Storage Wars,
one of the show’s stars began making noise
about producers tampering with their contents.
If something seems too good to be true, it
probably is.
And bid-master Dave Hester sued the network
for interfering.
He says he was fired in retaliation, but came
back to the series shortly after.
Man vs. Wild
Bear Grylls, a.k.a the guy who drank his own
pee, is the star of Man vs. Wild.
A show that finds him trying to survive the
most severe circumstances.
He’s rolled around inside the corpse of
a camel, and eaten some extreme stuff.
Audiences saw him devour snakes, spiders,
reindeer blood, and a moose heart to name
just a few.
But reports began to surface about the adventurer
routinely abandoning his rickety outdoor accommodations
as soon as the cameras quit.
Some suggest that while it may look like Grylls
spends the night shivering under a makeshift
lean-to in the middle of the Siberian wilderness,
he’s really snuggled up in a freshly-made
hotel bed.
Apparently that’s not the show’s only
trick either.
They also staged a bear attack in which a
costumed crew member ran at the host, and
the team played it off as a legitimate near-death
experience.
The Biggest Loser
Despite its seemingly negative title, The
Biggest Loser claims to be a show about everyday
people taking control of their lives.
Personal trainers work with overweight participants
to help them shed pounds through changing
their diets and exercise routines.
And at the end of the day, whoever loses the
most weight is the winner.
But since the series debuted in 2004, multiple
contestants have spoken out about the cruel
conditions behind the scenes.
They allege that the workouts often lasted
around eight hours every day.
And that, while the show talks about the importance
of cutting calories, the crew took this idea
to the extreme, leading to some people becoming
severely ill, even malnourished.
Apparently, staffers said that anyone who
spoke up would be edited to look like a whiner.
After failing to maintain the facade of empowerment,
it turns out that the biggest loser is everyone.
The Bachelorette
We all want the storybook romance for ourselves,
but there are big risks associated with falling
in love.
Broken hearts, shattered egos, and nights
wasted waiting by the phone.
It’s much safer to just sit back and watch
it happen to someone else.
And thanks to the creators of The Bachelorette,
we can do that from the comfort of our living
rooms.
One bachelorette looks for her soulmate amongst
a pool of about 25 hopefuls.
They go on romantic group dates that usually
end in disaster, but there is the occasional
adorable moment.
However, previous contestants have accused
the show of roadblocking the majority of the
romance.
Creator Mike Fleiss has admitted that his
endgame is to create good television, not
play matchmaker.
Pimp My Ride
For a lot of people, their first vehicle is
a rite of passage.
And more often than not, it’s a clunker
that barely gets the driver from point a to
point b.
Auto maintenance doesn't come cheap, so it’s
often more practical to accept its quirks
instead.
But, for a brief period of time between 2004
and 2007, there was a small chance that Xzibit
would show up at your house and whisk your
car away to his friends at West Coast Customs.
Winners of Pimp My Ride had the pleasure of
having their cars “pimped”.
After a brief personality analysis, a team
of mechanics come up with crazy ideas for
add-ons and enhancements.
Then reveal the finished work to the owner.
The show boasts about a one week turnaround
time for each car, but some winners have said
the upgrades actually took months.
Plus, most people had to remove the mods because
they made the vehicles unsafe to drive.
Also, the team doesn’t even touch the engine.
Survivor
Charlie Parsons took the old “stranded on
a desert island” conversation and turned
it into an empire called Survivor.
Since the year 2000, viewers have been tuning
in to watch as the tribes battle hunger, and
each other, in a series of tests.
Alternating between physical and mental, whatever
tribe loses the challenge votes on which teammate
they want to send home.
In the show’s inaugural season, contestant
Stacey Stillman was the third person to be
cut from the team.
She then sued on the grounds that producers
were tampering with the voting process, arguing
that if they hadn’t interfered she might
have won.
That case was decided privately, but producer
Mark Burnett admits that some things were
fake.
The aerial and establishing shots were done
using stand-ins, that’s why we never see
any pesky cameramen in the background.
So what do you think of our list?
Did we miss any other reality TV lies?
Tell us about them in the comments below,
and subscribe to our YouTube channel for more
videos like this one.